[Music]
in a stunning display of courage a white
british tick tock influencer has
revealed to the world that he identifies
as korean
ali london is his name he's been getting
plastic surgery for several years
in an effort to as a newsweek article
puts it resemble their k-pop idol jimin
of bts
i have only a vague idea what any of
those words mean but the upshot
is that now london who also identifies
as non-binary has completed his surgical
transition and is ready to fully live
his life as the gender fluid korean that
he's always been deep down
for too long he has had a korean trapped
inside his body and now
with 150 000 of assistance from cosmetic
surgeons
his true east asian self has emerged
like a bruised and swollen butterfly
from a fleshy cocoon in a video recorded
just after his latest procedure ali
explains
that his surgically adjusted eyes and
nose and other features
now confirm uh confirm him
as a tried and true korean and i think
the case that he makes is pretty
bulletproof
let's listen
hey guys i'm finally korean i've
transitioned
i'm so so happy i've completed my look
i'm finally korean guys i have the eyes
just had a brow lift as well um so i'm
so happy
finally i've been trapped in the wrong
body for eight years
and that's the worst feeling in the
world when you're trapped and you don't
feel
like you can be yourself but finally i'm
korean i can be myself
and i'm so so happy
he looks happy finally he is korean
it's as simple as that bigots might
voice disagreement insisting that one
must actually be from korea or at least
have korean citizenship
in order to be considered in any sense
korean they might even argue that
surgically narrowing your eyes to
resemble asian facial features not only
fails to make you asian but is also
highly insulting
and degrading to the real asians of
which you are not one but ali definitely
countered these arguments in a series of
tweets
disarming and debunking such
discriminatory talking points he wrote
being transsexual is the same as being
transracial because you're born in the
wrong body
in other tweets he announced that quote
trans rights are human rights
and that quote there are millions of
underrepresented transracial people in
the world
and i want to elevate their voices and
help them live their truth and be
themselves
now these may be more assertions than
arguments more spitting slogans than
making a case
but if if that's been sufficient for
transgender advocates then why shouldn't
it work for a trans-racial pioneer
driving the point home ali i think
really vanquished his critics once and
for all
by dropping the ultimate progressive
trump card in a different video listen
this is my reason for sharing the flag
and i do identify as korean this is my
choice this is my decision
it's not hurting anyone
there you go his decision his choice
not hurting anyone that's really it
right
in the age of psychological man when all
that matters is an individual's mental
states and all that you must do to
justify an
action is claim that the action makes
you feel good and causes no direct
physical harm to anyone else
whether or not the latter is actually
true the validity of a white man's
transformation in that context into a
genderless korean cannot be denied
certainly if you accept trans ideology
then you have absolutely
no logical basis for denying ali's truth
a truth which is grounded in the exact
same premise
a truth which must indeed be true if the
premise is true
and the premise to remind you is that a
person's physical biological identity is
totally determined by how they feel
about themselves a man who feels like a
woman is not merely a feminine man but
is
actually a literal woman all of the
physical barriers which have for
millennia serve to separate
men from women are dissolved and
discarded biology is subordinated
to the emotional whims of the individual
why should ali's emotional whims not be
afforded the same supernatural weight
his case um based on the logic of
progressivism is airtight
based on the logic of well logic it's
not at all but based on the logic of
progressivism it is
and yet the left has not accepted him
comments on the internet about his
racial transition have been
overwhelmingly negative
the daily wire documents a few of them
reading now it says i'm sorry but you
can't just choose to be korean
it's a nationality and ethnicity tweeted
one trans-identifying account
you have to be born korean just because
you like the culture doesn't mean you
could take it and
become it there is a way to appreciate a
different culture this is not it
quote as a korean non-binary person i
haven't really talked about the ollie
london thing but the fact that they're
acting like it's genuine that it's part
of a journey
due to an identity issue really irks me
it's a mockery of trans people
it's cultural appropriation posted
another person finally one korean user
replied that while he celebrated
uh london's new gender identity it's
wrong for him to claim a new ethnic
identity
korean isn't a pronoun nor is it a
persona you decide to suddenly take on
because of k-pop hype
i'm glad you identify as non-binary and
i applaud you for being transparent
about that
but i can't commend you for taking a
whole ethnicity
and treating it like a persona hmm
taking a whole ethnicity and treating it
like a persona
almost like when someone takes a
biological sex and treats those
i don't know an article in the left-wing
paper mag written by sandra song
editor at large and a fellow korean is
just one long transphobic harangue
against the entire trans-racial
community
song writes quote as someone who
actually has korean dna though
i can say that some white fetishist as
proven by those 15 surgeries to look
look like jimin suddenly deeming
themself korean
is incredibly offensive especially since
it effectively trivializes our
identities
because they're suddenly trendy
apparently though that doesn't really
register for ali who's continually been
a notable example of western
fetishization
that's objectified us based on south
korea's recent contributions to global
culture
so yeah obviously it's pretty sus that a
white person is tr
is saying they're korean now leaving
aside the embarrassing fact that the
magazine's editor-at-large wrote and
published the words
so yeah and pretty sus the real problem
is that she would accuse a person of
fetishizing
and trivializing her identity simply
because he is cartoonishly mimicking her
appearance and claiming that his
degraded mockery
is as authentic as her own identity i
mean she's essentially arguing
that his imitation is an imitation
and thus cannot be as valid or real as
the thing he is imitating
and her points make a lot of sense come
to think of it
but unfortunately she like nearly
everyone else in her ideological camp
has already thrown open the doors and
invited men to
fetishize and trivialize and mimic her
identity
it's just that she wishes the mimicry
would stay contained to her sex not her
ethnicity
the problem though is that sex is far
more objective
and far less fluid than ethnicity
if the former can be erased then so can
the latter
ali london knows that and now he's
entitled to
be seen as fully korean just as korean
as any other korean
indeed he may be even more korean than
cis koreans
like sandra song i mean you can make
that argument
this at least was a choice that he has
made
bravely if cis koreans don't want to
tolerate or accept trans koreans
that's their problem and their bigotry
they have to work through
it'd be better for them to just remain
silent in the meantime while the march
of progress continues
and all objective markers of identity
are erased
and human existence is reduced to a
murky puddle of ambiguity
that is the world the left wanted and
now they have it
congratulations and that is why the
bigots who would deny the validity of
ali london's korean identity
are today absolutely and with great
righteous rage cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated